Time for me to review what you have been up to last week
I asked you to make a thumbnail for this video. I'm sure there's not gonna be any racism
When I click in here right? I won't be disappointed at all
Right? No racism on this channel. This is Christian channel now.
No, racist yuck.
I can get in trouble, please, please for real guys. Please don't. I'm serious no no racism, okay
*No fucking racism*
No racis- I asked for a thumbnail guy- didn't want to look
I don't even want to look at this because you know it's gonna be bad. I'm a Christian Channel now
Thank you, also next week. I want you to submit poems right, because we're a Christian channel now. God damn it
Let's get into this the truth about Jake Paul.
That does not even look like his fucking face
That just looks terrible, I mean, it's a good thumbnail, i'll give you this, it's a good thumbnail.
It just doesn't look anything like Jake Paul legit fam, I can scramble this shit together in like two seconds.
There you go, took me two seconds, two seconds exactly and it's less shitty than this go home
Go home and try again, and do you goddamn homework you think you can do my thumbnails pathetic.
**spits**
disgusting I'm quitting YouTube thumbnail
Okay, good use of emoji well done for that the rest is garbage, okay what the hell is this outline?
What the hell is this? What are you fucking stupid? I can't read that
Look this is you: "oh I should just had a stroke on this"
"Oh okay, should I change the blend mode to substract yeah, that looks good"
"Wow"
Fuck off get out of my get out of my goddamn house. Oh, this is actually really cute, and I really appreciate it, thank you
It's the wrong challenge though, oh, this is really good
This is a really good original thumbnail. This is a this is the best one so far
This is really good. It was love at first sight
Hi nice to meet you. You look good. Can I touch you ?
The fun times we had
Your door locked
notice me senpai. It's about to get steamy
FIST ME!
I peed myself
But then
This happened, this is this is my new girlfriend. I'm stopping. I'm gonna stop it right there
I'm stopping it
No more no more. No more.
Pewds favorite cold beverage
That is an ice cream you f-fff idiot
Learn the difference. This
I see what you're doing here
Well done, okay?
You think I would make mistake a beverage with the wonderful Nogger
filled- an-and a cooling ice cream filled with no goat
I Don't think so. Try again
Hey? The secret CEO of Wall Street Journal
Wow, what a great thumbnail. It looks so well Photoshop, I really like how you added CEO on his little thing
Just in case there was any doubt that this was fake. Well done. Why I joined Game of Thrones
Well well good use of circle here for no reason whatsoever
That's how you know. It's a good circle if you add it
No reason, but you're like
Probably, I probably shouldn't click, but I want to know I want to know that it's a circle. God. Damn it
I need to know where it goes. Hairdryer that your wamon deserves. Respect?
Does it really say that on the thing?
Finally a hair dryer that respects my hair
Simple, yet so modern. No that is the ugliest goddamn, font you could ever pick. What the hell is that, impact?
Yeah, red font with white outline
What are you? Blind? My response to my response and my response (will delete later)
I like this one. It has many layers of irony
But still works as a clickbait. Well done. You know what this could be a champion
This k-ehehehehe
Didn't know what to name the goddamn video. I was like ah
My response, but didn't I do that literally six months ago?ahh fuck it. No one's gonna notice
Goddammit you know what this is good
I'm gonna keep a tab open for this one PewDiePie trophy 3d printed and available to everyone for [download]. Oh, that's awesome
Hell yeah, well done
Well done, bro. Oh, there's all kinds of stuff here
What?
Is that 3d printed? No flipping way
So you paint you painted it. I didn't know this is a thing. Scaring Nick Crumpton on our first
date
no
Everyone's seen that stupid meme pic of him okay. Everyone knows. That's not the real thing that happened, disappointed. Disappointed
Marzia cheated on me with markiplier
Wow, what an excellent Photoshop here, you can really sell how well you fucking blend it my god?
Just let me blend the fucking hair next time just blend the fucking hair next time make it somewhat
Goddamn, believable my god look at that
Was that so hard, get out. I don't want you on my side. Git out
Go you should just leave oh
OHHHH
Go just go away from me the door is right there
Thank you very much. Goodbye
Goodbye, I don't want to see you and your shitty memes anymore. Goodbye
Let's play Firewatch 2 this game is awesome
I like this too. It's clever. It's clever. It's a shit thumbnail. I'm not gonna lie, but it's a clickbait
It's a pretty good. It's pretty funny. It's topical. It's humorous, and it sparks an interest hmm
Did he really play fire watch 2? I fucked up?
Do you know what it's funny and all look at the aspect ratio on this shit?
Look at that how am I gonna upload this thumbnail? It's gonna look like this
You know that right? Garbage. Maybe you're going for that cinematic effect. Actually you know what I like it now well done. Thumbnail
So goddamn lame. Oh my god
How did it end up like this? How did how did it get so lame the truth?
What happened about ainsley. I knew it I had my doubts, but I knew there's this really real image
Makes it true. How am I gonna use? This as a thumbnail? I'll make a better one
I'll make goddamn better one
Just look like a weighted alien penis isn't it I always thought about that, but I was always too too afraid to admit it
There you go not that hard
You've heard of Elf on a shelf now get ready for pootie on the booty.
Oh my god is this-
You made everyone I love into thumb nails
This is the dumbest and cutest thing I have ever seen in my life
Even marzia is a thumbnail
It's just really the best thing I could cover, it's amazing well done
The holy foot, well done. ERTH IS FLET. The truth about ERTH.
That's good, are y- you took a picture that's not that comment. It's from my livestream. So it makes it seem more credible ah
I've got a funny funny meme in there
Not bad. Except you can't read it. Clearly you can't read what this says, okay? You're gonna make a thumbnail
You got to make it readable. I can't read shit. Whoa look at that Hedgehog hair. Holy crap. That's cool though. Thank you
I like it. Marzia keep saying that I look like doggy or a hedgehog, and I see it I see it now
Ireland is my city. This is good
This is really good Photoshop cuz he got the lighting right almost
The sharpness is clearly off, but considering the fact that it's a thumbnail. You won't really see all the details so
That's pretty good.
Oh my god
You crook crush edit crook added a mini Felix that is amazing
Ibowlin0912. That's so cool. Thank you so much. I love seeing the creativity like this
That's so awesome. I think we have a few good contenders. I will evaluate my options, but until then
See you next time. I really appreciate that you guys
Support me. Even when I fuck up
I shouldn't keep getting chances like this and I know that and I'm not planning to make a whole buckle again
Okay, I've learned my lesson and i, i really just want to move on, but I think
Maybe some people will think I don't take it seriously "cause I laugh at all these memes or whatever
But and I really appreciate you guys
making these submissions. Thank you for cheering me up and being supportive when I need you that really means a lot.
Thanks for leaving like on this video [it] really helps me out a lot and remember to subscribe
Squad fam out. Oh, and I forget next week
Poems that's right. I challenge you it says we're a Christian channel now. I challenge you to write some poetry to me